Let's now discuss how you
can make your App Engine
application more performant and
cost less using Memcache.
So far, you've learned a lot
of things about Google App
Engine, including the
architecture, the services,
the datastore, and
lots of APIs.
If you say that those features
are like the bread and butter
of App Engine, then you can
also say Memcache is like
coffee for App Engine.
Your App Engine application
can be very functional
without, just more performant
using Memcache.
That's why Memcache is such an
addictive feature for a lot of
developers.
Just like caffeine has side
effects, however, using
Memcache has some caveats
and limitations.
You must use Memcache
with care.
Here are the topics we're going
to cover in this lesson.
First off, I'll talk about
what Memcache is.
What are the general uses?
And then I'll talk about some
specific benefits of using
Memcache, and to highlight
why we need it.
Then I'll cover how
to use Memcache.
I'll talk about the Java and
Python APIs for your
application to access
Memcache.
Then we'll move to some
more advanced topics.
We'll talk about some caveats
with using Memcache and what
the general solutions will be.
What is Memcache?
Simply put, Memcache
is an in-memory
key-value pair datastore.
The datastore is sitting
in memory.
That's why it's much faster
compared with other datastores
sitting on disk.
It's also very easy to use.
The only thing you can put in
Memcache are key-value pairs.
So you put a value into the
Memcache associated with a
key, and you expect to get
that value back later on.
You can actually put anything
that is serializable into
Memcache either as a
key or as a value.
It's really kind of language
independent.
In both Java and Python, you can
put in any object with its
serializable interface.
In Python, the object has to
be serialized for using the
pickle module.
Watch for some future
enhancements on the roadmap to
support non-serializable objects
in the near future.
You could almost put anything
into Memcache.
In general, there are only two
major use cases, however.
The first use case for Memcache
is to do caching.
For example, you can cache in
the datastore query results,
or some user authentication
tokens, or session data.
One typical example
is a URL fetching.
You can actually cache
the content of
the page into Memcache.
You can also cache some other
computational results.
The second use case is to share
data across different
application instances.
One typical example is an
application level counter.
Because multiple instances
access the same counter, you
have to pay attention to race
conditions, for example.
Fortunately, Memcache actually
provides the mechanism to help
you to implement the counter
very easily.
Why do we need Memcache?
You can use datastore
to share data
across different instances.
You can even use datastore
to do the caching of
the counter API call.
So what kind of benefits will
Memcache bring to us?
We can summarize this
into two points.
The first is to improve
application performance.
The second we don't talk enough
about, is that it can
actually reduce your
application's operational cost.
Unlike most technologies, you
can actually obtain both
benefits together.
Let's look at performance
first.
Notice on the left here with a
simple data store query that
it takes about 100 milliseconds
in App Engine.
But for a Memcache read on the
right, it takes less than 10
milliseconds.
Therefore, Memcache is actually
more than 10 times
faster than the data
store query.
If a request is already in
Memcache and finds the
results, there's no need
to go to the datastore.
This means the request
and the response
can be 10 times faster.
If you have a very good hit rate
from Memcache, you can
experience a huge performance
improvement for your
application.
How about from a cost
point of view?
Zero.
That's simple.
It's free.
But for the datastore query,
you have to pay for it.
For API calls, you have
to pay for it.
For your application,
that CPU memory, you
have to pay for it.
So think about this--
if 90% of the requests can be
handled by Memcache, and
there's no need to go to the
datastore or do the API call
or do the computation, that
could be a huge savings for
your application.
That will make your manager
very happy about it.
So how do we use Memcache?
There are different ways to use
Memcache depending on the
language you're using.
If you're using Java, you can
use a high level JCache API,
which is actually a Java
standard for caching services.
App Engine implements most of
the JCache API, so people who
choose to use it are mainly
interested in application
portability versus using a
different caching service.
But App Engine is only
one caching service.
For a lot of developers, they
actually choose to use the
lower-level Memcache APIs.
The reason is, you can access
some extra functionality
provided by Memcache, for
example, the byte operation,
the automatic counter
manipulation, and also the
synchronized core.
Some developers don't
want to deal with
Memcache directly at all.
But they still want the
benefit of Memcache.
So they might use a third-party
library, like
Objectify for datastore, which
uses Memcache internally.
Similarly for Python, you can
choose to use a lower-level
API, like Memcache module,
which has a very similar
syntax as Open Source Project
Memcache D. You can also
choose to use NDB
for datastore.
I said you can use Memcache to
cache a datastore or to cash
API computations.
But actually, from a programming
point of view, the
usage pattern is all the same.
For the data read operation,
what you need to do is first
check to evaluate
the Memcache.
If it does contain your
data, perfect.
You just return the value.
If it doesn't--
for example, if it's
a datastore--
then you have to fetch the data
from the datastore and
update the cache entry.
For the write operation, you
also need to evaluate the
existing value in
Memcache first.
You can either evaluate the
specific entry, or you can
simply evaluate the
entire Memcache.
Because you want to write a new
value, then you can write
it to the datastore and
optionally load the value to
Memcache, as well.
Here is some Java sample code
that explains the read flow.
Similar to other App Engine
services, you get the Memcache
service object back.
Then you can start to
handle the class.
You try to do the read
from the cache.
And if the value is
there, perfect.
Otherwise, if the value is not,
then you have to get the
value from the datastore
and update the cache.
Similarly, this is
the Python code.
You implement the same
read workflow.
Also you can implement the put
operation for the write flow.
This is another feature that's
provided specifically by
Memcache that's basically a
batch operation to further
improve performance.
I talked about Memcache being
a shared service running on
some server.
Every API call is actually
a network call.
So if you try to read one
object, it's fine.
If you read 100 objects, that's
100 network calls.
The network overhead added
together could be
more than you want.
So what you can do is deal with
this common use case.
Memcache actually provides a
mechanism to do a batch.
You can batch 100 network calls
into a single network
call that further improves
Memcache performance.
The only limitation is the
batch size for your
operational API must be
less than 32 megabits.
Another important feature is
that Memcache has some generic
built-in support for
atomic operations.
The first are increment and
incrementAll that can
automatically increment
numerical values.
That's very useful feature to
implement some kind of counter
in Memcache.
Because Memcache is not
transactional, the API cannot
participate in the
transaction.
It does, however, provide some
very basic optimistic lock
mechanisms.
It provides the method
getidentifiable and
putifUntouched.
For example, you want to update
something, but worry
about others updating
at the same time.
What you can do is you can use
getidentifiable first.
What it does is return you
an identifiable object.
In this object contains the
value of what you need and
also a version of this value.
You can treat the version
as a time stamp.
Later on, when you want to
update the value, you don't
call put, but you call
putifUntouched and then pass
the identifiable object
as a parameter.
Memcache is guaranteed only
if this value has not been
changed or modified since
the last time you called
getidentifiable.
You will be able to update it.
If somebody updated
in between, it
will not do the update.
Here are some other features
provided by Memcache.
One is an asynchronous call.
Memcache is a shared service, so
a Memcache server could be
overloaded by either your
application or someone else's.
Your API can actually block
on the Memcache API.
For some applications, they are
very sensitive to latency.
What they can do is call
the asynchronous
version of the service.
What that does is the
API code is not
blocked it all by Memcache.
Then you can continue.
And then only when you need it,
you return back to sync
back with the API call.
Another feature is namespace.
Actually, namespace is a
generic feature that's
supported by the App
Engine itself.
There are many use cases
for namespace.
One typical use case is to
support multi tenancy.
For example, you have one
application, but you want to
support a different domain.
But you also want to isolate
the data between
the different domains.
So what you can do is use
namespace to put all the data
into one domain so they cannot
access each other.
We've covered the basics
about Memcache.
Now, let's discuss some caveats
and some solutions to
work around them.
The first caveat is Memcache
is volatile
compared with datastore.
Basically, if you put something
in Memcache, it does
not mean you can get
it back later on.
The reason is either the entry
has reached expiration, or the
Memcache is full.
You either put too much
data into it, or old
data will be evicted.
The Memcache server might also
crash, so you lose all your
data in Memcache.
It's therefore very important
for your application to handle
cache miss gracefully.
Either it's in the cache return
or not, or you get an
exception if the
server crashes.
If you really want persistence
behavior, you can implement
the write-through logic backing
Memcache with datastore.
Actually, that's exactly what
Objectify and NDB do, but you
can implement your own version
if you want flexibility.
Another caveat is Memcache
is not transactional.
Consider two running instances
where the first reads an
account in Memcache was $100.
Instance two deducts $20, and
then the Memcache becomes $80.
The first instance also deducts,
say, $30, and it
writes the incorrect value
of $70 to the Memcache.
I think you can see this
transactional problem.
You need to pay attention not
to fall into this caveat.
The mechanism provided by App
Engine, you can simply use
increment, treating the value
as a counter to do that.
But for other types of data,
or if you want more
flexibility, for example, you
can use getidentifiable.
Each instance, one and instance
two, both use
getidentifiable.
Then you can do a
lot of things.
When you do the update, using
putifUntouched, instance two
will succeed.
But instance one will fail,
because during that time the
value has been modified.
A lot of people find that they
don't have enough Memcache.
Even if you're willing to
pay for it, they ask,
can you give us more?
But until now, we couldn't.
In the future, maybe there's
some feature,
but not right now.
What we like to say is that
your application should
function well even without
Memcache, so that Memcache
only gives a boost on
the performance.
Also don't put too many items
into Memcache, because you can
make it less efficient
if you do that.
Think about one use case.
Memcache is one size.
You can only put one item into
Memcache, for example.
So you put item A in.
Then you try to put
item B into it.
Then A gets evicted.
So we need to try to read A.
Then A gets read in from the
datastore and then put
into Memcache.
Then B gets evicted.
Then you try to read B again.
And if you get that kind of
situation, Memcache doesn't do
you much good.
So what we suggest is your
application should put only
useful and necessary information
into Memcache.
More specifically, some
developers use
optimization like this.
They don't just blindly put
the entity read from the
datastore into Memcache.
Because probably only 20% of the
information is really what
you need cached, they
actually create
their own kind of objects.
And it combines information from
multiple entities and put
into the cache.
They even use some compression
to make
the object size smaller.
Those kinds of optimizations
you can do to make Memcache
more efficient.
But that's the cost you have--
you're coding it more.
These are some of the key
takeaways you should have
learned from this lesson.